did you know that Khan Academy just
launched their AI based education
chatbot it's called Khan mego and it's a
beta tool that is available your website
basically gives you a preview of what
the chatbot is going to look like and it
looks pretty legit I love Chad gbt I
love Bard for learning new things I've
been using those as a tutor but the
problem with those is that you actually
need to know the subject in order to
figure out what type of questions to ask
but if you're new in the subject you're
basically I don't know why I'm tilted
you're basically it's not that helpful
they're covering variety of topics
including coding and this example
actually looks pretty good it doesn't
give the answer straight away this is
what I love like if you ask tragically
is going to give you the answer and
you're not going to learn in this case
you give it a problem and it basically
encourages you to think about the
problem differently it gives you hints
which I kind of like because it's
important for learning that you are able
to like spend that time and figure it
out on your own there is currently a
wait list so if you are interested